I feel a frustration a constant whisper
that I am no closer to achieving my
dreams mister that's Shelley beautiful
isn't he just how old are you old enough
to know why you are asking from 16
only you I felt alive come away with me
oh you're really involved with that
whole manga I have a fire in my soul and
I will no longer allow you or anyone
else to contain it
who amongst you has ever wondered if the
dead could return to life is that really
possible
reanimation we've been invited to Geneva
I Lord Byron we should like to draw in
the polymers okay I have no qualms with
you becoming lovers you wished you were
someone else
I no longer see the world and it's works
they before appeared to me and men
appear to me as monsters we are each to
write a ghost story it's a competition
the woman is not intelligent enough to
form ideas of her own that's following
you miss God when I have the chance to
prove me wrong
Taji recognized Victor Frankenstein this
is no ghost story it chilled me to the
bone you must get your story published
marry curious subject matter for young
lady are you suggesting the work bones
to mr. shell it is my story
you dare question a woman's ability to
experience loss
betrayal death if I had known to fight
through the anguish I would not have had
this voice my choices made me who I am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you